hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm answering
a question from one of my newsletter
readers Daniel who wrote a lengthy email
so I'll try to kind of short it down
here for you guys so Evan I want to know
how to run an entrepreneurship training
and consulting company successfully I've
made several attempts in last year with
not-so-great results and it goes on what
what can I do to create greater
awareness and increase interest in this
field Thank You Daniel so great question
Daniel congratulations want to set up a
business I know it's really hard and
tough and there's definitely lot of
failures along the way I think with this
approach it's really hard to create
interest in a new field trying to create
a market is one of the hardest things
that you can do as an entrepreneur where
it's better to look at an existing
market and solve a challenge that
they're facing so for you if you're
selling entrepreneurship consulting and
training services some things to keep in
mind entrepreneurs generally don't have
a lot of money now if you're looking at
start-up entrepreneurs especially you
know they don't have a lot of money and
everything they make is going back into
their business or just to feed their
families you know it's it's it's hard
being a new entrepreneur and so it can
be really tough to to create really
valuable things that people will pay for
on when you're selling to entrepreneurs
and so you know I love helping startups
I love helping entrepreneurs most of
what I do is free just because it's it I
love doing it you know I love helping
entrepreneurs and so like these YouTube
videos I don't get paid to do these
YouTube videos but I want to answer your
question you know I get you ask me the
question I want to help out and I hope
other just can learn from these videos
as well and can grow their businesses so
you have to figure out a way to to make
money from what you're doing and so what
I would try to do is look at people who
may have more money who are interested
in that field and so the two ideas that
come to mind one are looking at
government so are there any government
organizations that are funding training
and
element and consulting services that you
might be able to tag along with I don't
know what's happened in your market and
here in Toronto we have a number of
different government programs where they
bring in people to come and deliver
training to entrepreneurs because it
helps the economy you know the more
entrepreneurs can build themselves up
hire people build their companies that
helps the local economy so government
sometimes have money that they can
invest into that to look at different
programs it can take longer to get in
with the government just because
governments tend to move slowly but it's
a good long-term solution to start to
look at the other thing I look at is
corporations and this is part of what I
do a lot of corporate companies will
come to me and say we're trying to reach
out to the entrepreneur community we're
trying to be seen as a friend to the
entrepreneurs and provide a lot of value
to them and the hope is you know the
more you interact with a company and see
that they're trying to help you out that
when you need products or services
you're going to go to them so if you
know just a lot of with Telus as an
example they sell phones here and phone
services in in Canada and I'll create a
little blog content for them and the
idea is the more content I create the
more people visit their website the more
telecine is a friend of the entrepreneur
community and when you're ready to buy
your phone you're likely more to go with
Telus and somebody else and so
approaching corporations who have an
interest in selling to small business
owners could be a great way to go you're
you're adding value for them you're
helping them get their message across I
never work with companies where it's
just a sales pitch it's more adding the
value and having them seen as a again
that friend of the entrepreneur
corporations have more money and can
invest into it and hopefully you get
paid what you're worth and you're still
able to follow your passion of helping
entrepreneurs and and helping them get
developed and trained and seeing them be
successful and be able to grow their
businesses out so I think the model can
work it's just maybe changing slightly
who pays you so you're changing your
structure a little bit but still serving
the same target audience there are two
biggest challenges again are looking at
you know trying to get money out of
startups which can be really hard and
you know you're never going to get paid
what you're worth and the second one is
that trying to create a new market is we
just really tough you know you want to
try to look at an established market and
build into it then to try to create a
brand new market yourself the only real
way that I can see to make money from
the startup entrepreneurs if that's
still your market that you want to go to
is you partner up with them and you
become a partner in the business you own
a piece of their business and you help
them grow and if you're you know really
good at what you do and they're really
good at what they do
it could all potentially work out but it
really depends on having the right
people together matching the skill sets
but also matching the personalities and
making sure you guys are going to get
along it's like getting the marriage you
know I ask you something that you're
both in for a very long period of time
and so that's really the way to make
money off of a startup type of business
but it's it's hard on your cash flow
because you're not making money right
away and it's really hard to pick the
right businesses to partner up with so
hopefully I gave you a few ideas in
there that you can use to to get your
business off the ground I'm excited for
you and hopefully you'll keep us posted
with your progress for those of you
watching the video if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
makes you want to do more for you and I
love to hear we have to think if you
want to leave a comment under the video
either about this video or a question
that you may have about your own company
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you